this is
one of those sort of obscure
geopolitical issues that's actually
very important and it's people you know
nerds
sit around and think about how to move
the chips of international relations
focus on this one but it does seem
pretty abstruse to most people so here's
the story
russia produces a lot of natural gas
germany is a
major issue the economic driver of
europe and it consumes a lot of natural
gas
so the germans and the russians got
together and they decided they built a
pipeline
it's called north stream it's going to
go across
it's an undersea pipeline that would
connect russia to germany and
provide germany with gas so russia and
germany agreed on this
everything was all set and in fact the
construction is almost finished
it's been going on for years it's
needless to say this is a
highly complex project and you have
germany and russia involved it's not
just like two little countries that
don't know anything
so this has been a massive undersea
project and a big undertaking
it's been going on for some years so
suddenly the united states decided
wait a minute we don't like this
pipeline because
it's going to make germany dependent
on russia it will give russia
a future pressure point against germany
and the german answer was let us worry
about that don't worry
we can handle our relations with russia
we're growing up we've had relations
with russia
long before there even was the united
states we're going to deal with this
and america says no we don't like that
we don't want you to have that pipeline
so as i say the pipeline is almost
completed and there's now sentiment not
just
in the trump administration but even in
congress that we have to stop this
pipeline and the trump administration
has now ordered a program of sanctions
against every company that's helping to
build that
pipeline this is like 800 companies
every company that owns a part of the
pier
in some port up in the baltic every
company that helps make the steel
tubes 800 companies from countries all
over europe
they're now sanctioned by the united
states if they dare
to help russia and germany complete a
project that russia and germany have
agreed on
if they if they help they can't do any
business with any american company
in the united in the future you'll be
sanctioned by the united states
government
this we are sanctioning germany germany
is our closest
uh ally in western europe it's the
economic powerhouse
it's the country that isn't the big
power in the central in the center of
europe and we're trying to tell germany
you have no idea how to deal with russia
let us tell you how to deal with russia
european politics are very old very
complex
they don't need somebody from america to
come over and tell them what to do
so here you have germany supposedly one
of our closest allies in the world
looking at washington and saying are you
kidding you're trying to
block a major energy project
that we need to fuel our economy that's
going to keep
our country and europe prosperous and
stable
how can you be doing this do you
overrule our sovereign right
to make contracts with other countries
and essentially that's what we're doing
so a new administration
could say to germany you know we think
you're grown up enough
to make your own decisions about your
relationships with russia
and we'll drop our fanatic belief that
anything that could be positive for
russia
is definitely bad for the world and
we'll let you go your own way
so that's an example of one project
the idea of sanctioning all companies
involved
in building this north stream pipeline
of how
a u.s president could make a dramatic
impact on foreign policy let me tell you
just lifting those sanctions and telling
the germans and the russians go ahead
and do whatever you decide you want to
do
but have a big impact especially in
germany it would convince germans that
a little bit of the nightmare might be
over in washington well
it's a fantastic example um who are the
specific people
in congress or in trump's cabinet
that are are making these decisions
and what would be their argument
to why they're doing this
so um secretary of state pompeo is one
of the leading
hard chargers on this issue he's the one
who officially signed the
new sanction rules on all these hundreds
of companies
in washington there are prominent
figures
in both parties uh who are promoting
this idea including adam schiff
powerful congressman uh who has made a
career
on uh confronting russia and that's
what's behind it all
it's all about congressman and senators
competing with each other to find new
ways to be tough on russia
you want to sanction russia here i'm
going to sanction them over there you
know we have
practically run out of sanctions we
don't have anything else we can do
it's just finding a new way to pile on
to russia
so someone noticed this nordstream
pipeline and say wait a minute
this could be good for russia anything
good for russia it's bad for us
that's the only reason and the reason is
to [ __ ] russia and in order to
promote that goal of making sure that
russia can't make money by exporting uh
gas to germany we are willing
to try to overrule a sovereign decision
taken by
one of our closest allied countries and
i just want to go back to this story
the relationships among european
countries russia
france germany poland these are very
complex very old they go back
many many centuries and uh
i think these countries have developed a
degree of diplomatic sophistication
where they
should be allowed to be free to decide
what's good for us
without politicians in washington going
nuts and telling them
you can't build this pipeline and let me
tell you it has nothing to do with the
pipeline itself
it has all to do with finding a way to
poke your stick in putin's eye one more
time
which always feels good in washington um
and i mean it seems like p like
especially countries over in europe
they're all so
jammed tight next to each other like
well
this is a very important factor
in explaining the difference in attitude
between european countries and the
united states
european countries as you put it are
packed together they all have lots of
neighbors so
before switzerland can take a step it
has to think so what's
austria going to do before austria can
take a step it has to think what about
france what about hungary what about
germany
and this is the way they've been
accustomed to dealing over many many
generations
so diplomacy is highly developed in
in europe more than anywhere else in the
world and that's the reason why
they've had to deal with shifting
alliances and balances of power over so
many centuries
but the united states is not like that
we never had to learn how to get
along with anybody we just have solid
mexicans and happy canadians and rapidly
declining fish stocks
that's it we never had to weigh
our actions uh against possible
reactions
in addition our geographic isolation
has been a spectacular way to protect us
against
the backlash from our decisions when
france or
germany or austria or poland has
historically made any decision
if it turns out badly they get the bad
result right away
we it doesn't happen to the united
states we're totally invulnerable or at
least that's what we thought until 9 11.
so this is why i tell my students at the
beginning of every semester
uh don't never underestimate the value
and importance of geography
in understanding the world and an
effectiveness on the united states is
we never had to learn how to deal with
neighbors we don't know how to play
nicely with others we don't have to
and also we're protected from the
blowback
from the effects of our foreign
interventions
because we got this huge distance
between us and all other countries
and that's probably uh an important
factor in
explaining how we came to be the way we
are